the following content is provided under  a Creative Commons license your support  will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to  offer high quality educational resources  for free to make a donation or view  additional materials from hundreds of  MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at  ocw.mit.edu client coming in and being  judges and Robin will coordinate its  information ok bye ok so tomorrow we'll  have class in a regular classroom 30 for  30 one same time Tranzit well there will  be course evaluations so your chance to  tell us how you actually felt about the  portion what you like  like afterwards we'll have an award  ceremony so for the winning team you'll  get some prizes and you'll get some cake  and then that will take us to around  11-1130 which time we'll come back to  saga and seventh floor lamp will have  pizza and more food for you guys to  enjoy so thank you tomorrow